So now that captain rogers and iron man are both
gone who do you think's gonna lead the avengers
I could lead them
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new eternals video all about the black knight
kit harrington's character who's going to be a big
deal going forward in marvel phase 4 in the future
of the mcu so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos we're doing a new giveaway
for disney plus memberships because the marvel
loki episodes are starting i'll be doing videos
for all those as well all you have to do to enter
is just be a subscriber and let me know which of
the movies you want to see kit harington's black
knight character cross over into besides avengers
5. kill one stark two more rise up in his place
because per kevin feige when they cast kit
harington it was for way more the idea was
there would be way more than just this one-off
appearance in the eternals movie so this is the
video of him talking about that it's heard
kit harington added right yes he's a really
amazing actor and this part came up in the
eternals film that we're doing we were so happy
when he agreed to join and it is a part that could
perhaps grow into something else in the future
so when he says something more obviously he's
talking about future avengers movies because if
you're not a big comic book reader this version
of the black knight that kit harington is playing
he's sort of like the main version there have
been many versions in the comics but he's just
the biggest version he debuted during an avengers
comic book and he was a big member of the avengers
across many different iterations of the team
over the years but as you can see he obviously
has a very different type of origin story he's a
pure fantasy character that they tried to weave
in with the more traditional marvel characters
like iron man thor captain america one of the
big reasons why they have that avengers end game
tag scene at the end of that what do you think
is gonna happen who's gonna lead the avengers
now that captain rogers and iron man are gone
notice they say gone and not dead even though
we're pretty sure that iron man died because
they burned the body and they scattered his ashes
across the lake next to his house so they just
want to let you know through this teaser and just
sort of explain who these weird characters are
because they're very different types of characters
in the mcu that go way back to the origin of the
mcu the origin of the universe but also show
you that they will be crossing over with the
traditional avengers characters in the next couple
of avengers movies here's a really important quote
from the black knight himself though this is kit
harington's version of the character in the comics
yes by heaven and by the armored ancestor who
bestowed the black blade upon me that's the ebony
blade i'll explain that in a second because it's
a stormbreaker level weapon i shall follow them
talking about the avengers in some way somehow so
swears the black knight and then obviously down
here just the tag scene teasing his next story
says next end game we just had avengers end game
and they're referencing the events of avengers
end game during the eternals trailer right after
kit harington's character shows up so traditional
mcu style everything is connected but i'll explain
the origins of the character how his ebony blade
weapon works how his armor works and how he sort
of fits in with these other characters during the
movie and what kit harington's arc is going to be
during the film because there will be a couple
minor changes to his comic book backstory they're
already changing some of the things about the
eternal's backstory that i explained in my last
big eternals trailer video so i'll link that at
the end of this but the original version of the
black knight was called sir percy he debuted in
a mini-series in the 1950s he was created by stan
lee like a lot of classic marvel characters but it
was actually during the era when marvel was still
called atlas comics so there were a couple
different names that marvel went by before
they became marvel they started as timely comics
stanley started working there in the 1930s then in
the 1950s timely comics just rebranded as atlas
comics that's the era where the original black
knight was created in this mini series then during
1961 that's when they rebranded as marvel comics
but stanley originated the character in just a
straight up black knight mini series established
a lot of the lore for the character that they then
passed on and incorporated with future versions of
the character when they passed the title down
obviously unfortunately stanley has passed away
so they can't have a stanley cameo during the
eternals movie in the movie was filmed after he
passed away but i'm sure they'll find some cool
way of including some stanley easter eggs when
some of these characters pop up for the first
time they kind of did a version of that during
the venom 2 trailer because there was a stanley
cameo during the first venom movie they have the
venom symbiote rearranging the comic books with
stan lee's face on the cover as he's walking out
of the bodega so just look for something on
that level when we get to the eternals movie
but the original version of the character just
debuted in this really small mini series it was
pretty straight up fantasy there wasn't anything
special tying it to the other marvel characters at
the time it was set during the 6th century during
the king arthur chronicles and this version of the
character this black knight serves king arthur
as his greatest warrior the main villain of that
story was mordred because we're talking about the
king arthur mythology his weapon that he wields is
the ebony blade which was forged by merlin from
a meteor rock it was kind of like sir arthur
dayne's ancestral sword and song of ice and fire
game of thrones because we're talking about kid
harington we're talking about robb stark richard
madden both being in the movie nice big game of
thrones reunion what a coincidence that the last
time those two characters robb stark and jon snow
met each other he said next time i see you
you'll be dressed all in black and so he was
if you never watched the rest of game of thrones
that's because robb stark and jon snow never
actually do meet each other robb stark winds up
being assassinated at the red wedding before jon
snow can see him again you also have to remember
in the mcu there's a lot of other extraterrestrial
materials that they use on planet earth the
biggest being vibranium vibranium comes from
a giant meteorite that crashed to earth but that
original sir percy version of the character was
killed by mordred during the fall of camelot at
the end of that mini-series but then merlin casts
a spell that will bring back his spirit if mordred
also finds a way to come back from death so much
later in the timeline after the kit harington
dane whitman version of the character takes up
the title of the black knight the ghost of that
original sir percy character shows up every once
in a while to give him counsel the ebony blade
is the main vessel for their family's curse
that's laid on the black knight's descendants the
explainer behind the curses is that original sir
percy version of the black knight spilled so much
blood with the blade that caused it to pick up the
curse the side effects of the curse are the more
blood you spill with it the more your body will
begin to turn to stone eventually the dane whitman
black knight does succumb to the curse and turns
to stone for a little while in the comics but
then they free him of that doctor strange is a
big crossover character because dane whitman is a
very fantasy magical based character dr strange is
one of the biggest magical characters in the mcu
so of course they'll probably have some crossover
with those characters in the future but at various
points doctor strange has tried to free him of the
curse but the curse always winds up coming back
it's sort of the way they balance the character
because the blade itself has so many storm breaker
level powers he'd be way too op if they didn't
have some debuffs to lay on it some of those storm
breaker level powers that the ebony blade has is
that it can basically cut through almost anything
except for adamantium vibranium and other equally
powerful weapons like it probably couldn't cut
through stormbreaker it can cut down magical
barriers it can deflect energy it can absorb all
forms of energy as long as some part of his body
is touching the blade he cannot be killed unless
you're talking about the one above all the one
below all like the most powerful beings in the mcu
for the most part he's immortal when he's wielding
the blade some of the newer comics explained that
his mystical armor actually comes from the blade
itself the same way in the first thor movie you
see thor's armor sort of activate when he wields
mule near he becomes worthy again it's kind of
the same situation with the ebony blade so i'm
assuming that they'll do it a similar way during
the mcu movies when we actually see him show up
in his full armor like in this scene when they're
inside the eternal spaceship and makari is reading
from all the books you even see the psvr unit
that's underneath there all the other artifacts
they've accumulated over human history from all
these different cultures and different eras of the
world history the big suit of armor that's right
next to her is meant to foreshadow black knight
kit harington even though that itself is not his
black knight armor the blade gives him the power
of flight and it can absorb souls to make itself
stronger and gives him a healing factor but that
kind of goes hand in hand with making him immortal
like he takes damage but it doesn't kill him
so the blade is so powerful that's why they have
the curse to explain how they sort of balance him
out otherwise he'd be the most powerful character
in the mcu that's how they explain the infinity
gauntlet it gives you ultimate power but it also
is enough to almost kill thanos just to try and
use it iron man dies trying to use it because
the power is too great for him to withstand
there are some other cooler weirder powers that
it has like supposedly the blade can't be used
against its owner and the blade itself is sort of
passed down to dane whitman so it's not completely
like the enchantment that's all mjolnir like only
the worthy can wield it but it's kind of like that
but just like mjolnir in stormbreaker he
can summon the blade from anywhere he has
a mystical talisman and he says avalon and
it basically brings all of his gear to him
but also he can use it to teleport the same way
the thor opens the bifrost with stormbreaker
but what happened in the comics is that stanley
introduces the second version of the black knight
character in the 1960s after the first one gets
killed off and it was during an ant-man giant man
wasp storyline the second version of the character
though is actually dane whitman's uncle and he's
actually the villainous black knight they just
call him black knight too he winds up joining
baron zemo's masters of evil we just saw baron
zemo and falcon and winter soldier they're sort
of setting him up for a thunderbolt's arc so maybe
someday we'll see a version of masters of evil but
i'm not really expecting it anytime soon he winds
up dying trying to kill iron man and the rest of
the avengers and as he lay dying he repents and
tells dane whitman his nephew all the secrets of
their family and basically bestows upon him
their family's castle so when dane whitman
is going to explore this family castle that he's
just inherited he finds a secret passageway that
leads him to the ebony blade then eventually he
joins the avengers on a version of their roster
it really wasn't until later in like the 1980s
that he developed the romance with the sersi
character of the eternals it got pretty spicy
around the same time his character was also in
a bit of a love triangle with crystal of the
inhumans i know everybody wonders what they're
going to do with the inhumans because just like
the eternals they're a really weird jack kirby
group that kind of obscure in marvel comics it'll
be much simpler for the mcu version of all this i
think as long as she doesn't go mad and he doesn't
wind up having to kill her we'll be fine like
oh no it's happening again it's happening again
but the whole idea is that kit harington's
black knight and you have gemma chan sersi will
eventually join a future version of the avengers
obviously richard madden here thinks that he's
going to lead the next version of the avengers
in avengers 5 but all the other eternals
kind of laugh them out like huh yeah right
but they're teasing this love triangle between
kit harington's character gemma chan and richard
madden in the movie clearly in the footage you
can see dane whitman knows nothing of the eternals
but just as the movie is meant to tell you the
origin of the mcu in a cosmic sense the origin
of the eternals the origin of the celestials kind
of an origin of the infinity stones as well even
though they already gave us that explainer during
the first guardians of the galaxy movie and then
again during avengers infinity war the movie will
also be a big origin story for the black knight of
the mcu the idea with his character just based on
the way they've explained him so far is that the
movie's supposed to set him up as a scientist or
an archaeologist type of character indiana jones
within the mcu who discovers some of the secrets
of the eternal spaceship here that they kept
cloaked and hidden on earth for thousands of years
sersi's character is the one who encounters him
because she's so in love with the idea of humanity
she loves humans so much like you see her in all
this different trailer footage helping them learn
how to farm helping them develop towns and cities
so amongst the eternals she's the most connected
to humanity so she's sort of the one that
encounters him first she's the one that eventually
winds up explaining who they really are all their
secrets their history the real history of the
world in the mcu to him but for the most part i
believe during the movie he's just supposed to be
the dane whitman character trying to help her and
the rest of the eternal stop the deviants and stop
the celestial host from destroying the earth and
then i think the idea is that towards the end of
the film or at the end of the movie he'll finally
receive the ebony blade itself and that's meant
to be the teaser for him becoming full comic book
black knight the next time he appears in a movie
there were rumors about kit harington while they
were filming the eternals movie doing full motion
capture and at the time people assumed that that
meant that they would be doing his black knight
armor as full motion capture the same way they
do the iron man armor and all the marvel movies
the avengers movies robert downey jr just kind
of walks around with a bunch of dots on him then
later special effects wizards come along and add
the armor in post-production but they could be
doing motion capture for his character for a
number of different reasons he'll probably
be in some of the bigger action scenes and
battles but for the most part it sounds like him
being full-blown black knight won't happen until
either the sequel like eternals 2 whatever that
winds up being or avengers 5 or whichever big mcu
movie he appears in next like i said the other big
character that he shares a lot in common with and
connection is doctor strange because he comes from
this very magical place his powers his abilities
the curse that's on the ebony blade but a lot
of that story they tend to speedrun during big
avengers movies so we'll see i don't know if there
are any plans to include his character in any kind
of marvel disney plus series but i'm sure if the
eternals franchise actually spins up if the movie
does well they do sequels eventually they might
do a disney plus series that spins out of some
of their characters but everybody let me know in
the comments what do you think about kid harington
joining the mcu and if you have any big questions
about his character the black knight how he sort
of fits in with the other avengers characters just
let me know in the comments and i'll cover it when
i do more eternals videos we will be getting more
trailers real soon and like i said next big thing
in a couple weeks we'll be getting those loki
episodes all my videos for that will post on
wednesdays just because that's when new episodes
drop so be sure to enable alerts for my channel so
you don't miss any of those congratulations shadow
prince you're the giveaway winner from my last big
marvel video please email me on the about page
of my channel so i can get your contact details
everyone click here for my full eternals trailer
video and easter eggs connections to the other
marvel movies and click here for my brand new loki
trailer video with all that episode one footage
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!